one thing that makes google cloud
production ready and ops friendly
is the broad range of management
monitoring and alerting tools that it
comes with
while tools are no magic wand and do not
replace
devops or sre practices you should
really watch this video to better
understand what they're all about
[Music]
now before i start talking about
specific tools
let me mention that these products work
best in the context of a team applying
sre or site reliability engineering
principles
there's not enough time to delve into
this but you'll find links to
sre literature on service level
objectives
or slos error budget and blameless
postmortems in the video description
below
the hello world for devops tools is
arguably the ability to collect
read and parse logs across a distributed
infrastructure
involving multiple products cloud
logging
stores logs across all google cloud
products and provides you with search
monitoring and alerting capabilities
it also comes with an api to ingest
custom log data from any source
because it is a fully managed service
there are no hard drives to provision or
petitions to resize
and it can ingest application and system
log data
from thousands of sources simultaneously
even better you can analyze all the log
data
as it arrives in real time without
having to worry about synchronizing your
server clocks or managing time zones
logs are made up of
entries created by google cloud services
third-party applications
or by your own code the message
carried by the log entry is called the
payload
and it can be a simple string or
structured data
examples of log entries can include
details of a compute engine instance
starting up
a new file being uploaded to a bucket a
call made to a machine learning api
or anything that your application writes
to the standard or
error outputs each log entry indicates
where it came from
by including the name of the monitored
resource
using the console's logs viewer you can
query logging data and obtain
a precise subset of all the log entries
in your project
the query will let you find entries for
a given resource
from different namespaces based on the
log level
and of course by timestamp note that if
using the console
isn't your thing these queries are also
accessible from the logging api
as well as from the command line storing
logs
is free for the first gigabytes for
every project
and then comes at 50 cents per
additional gigabyte
an alerting policy can be set up to
trigger when your monthly logs ingested
exceeds a given limit
but you can also define excluded logs so
that some
are not stored in the first place the
logs viewer
and the logs api are powerful tools on
their own
but you can also decide to export your
logs
to cloud storage to bigquery or to pop
sob
which then in turn redirects them to
virtually any log storage system
exporting logs is likely something that
you will want for archival or
potentially legal purposes
but also maybe to benefit from more
advanced analytics
there's even more to logs but hopefully
this gives you a good sense
of what every google cloud product can
rely on so now you know how logs are
aggregated
across all of google cloud and how to
navigate them
if you like this video please like
subscribe comment share
and look forward to more google cloud
essentials videos
you